[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le pr donc voilà chez avec dylan
styliste de tpm paix qu'on adore et
aujourd'hui on va tester ensemble des
tatouages parce que justement il en a
pas et s'est dit qu'il faudrait essayer
de s'en faire bon peut-être on va
commencer avec un petit mois j'en ai
déjà fait 1 chez vous ben voilà on le
voit donc voilà il est en bus étaient
choqués c'est un cru que c'était un vrai
que ça s'appelle tattoo star je vais
vous donner le site et vous avez en plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rien mais qu'on regarde son blog
puy du fou rire
aujourd'hui on la construit et là mais
son petit frère
la même tête
[Applaudissements]
bon je pourrais dire qu'on est à l'arrêt
total dans les embouteillages est ce que
tu crois vraiment que whitney houston et
céline dion sont dans la zone au
teillage quelque part alors oui ce n'est
sûr que non pas en revanche c'est dit
peut-être
[Applaudissements]
c'est un défi dance
à
quand tu arrives dans un magasin de
bricolage notes et même pas encore fait
froid le fil du temps
oh la la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]